in this video I want to talk about the
DNA polymerases in prokaryotes and
eukaryotes so we'll start off with
eukaryotes because they're simple and
they really only have one DNA polymerase
that we're going to be concerned with
prokaryotes however have three in the F
DNA polymerase one two and three so
eukaryotes their DNA polymerase
synthesizes five prime to three prime
and it has three prime to 5 prime
exonuclease activity I'll talk about why
that excellent activity is important in
just a second so now let's talk about
DNA polymerase one two and three how
they're similar how they're different if
there is anything special about any of
these how many of them synthesize 5
prime to 3 prime all of them DNA
polymerase always synthesizes 5 prime to
3 prime always so all of them synthesize
500 3 prime now how many of them have 3
prime to 5 prime exonuclease activity
all of them now what is exonuclease
activity what is nucleus activity let's
look look at this really quickly as an
aside so there are these things called
nucleases a nuclease is an enzyme that
degrades nucleic acids so DNA is a
nucleic acid RNA is a nucleic acid if
something is a nuclease it can degrade
nucleic acids there are two subclasses
of nucleic acid or nucleases and those
are exonucleases and endonucleases
exonucleases they act on the ends of the
strands so if this is the DNA a double
strands DNA molecule and this is an
exonuclease exonucleases could start
cutting off the the monomers at the end
so it could act here okay or here
endonucleases
they can cut the interior of the strands
so they can act here they get act here
they could act here who knows where they
could act like an act somewhere in the
interior okay so now knowing that let's
think about what exonuclease activity me
in terms of these DNA polymerases well
so we mentioned they all have 3 prime to
5 prime exonuclease activity and they
all synthesize 5 prime to 3 prime let's
think about this the idea behind that is
that if they're all synthesizing they've
made their 5 prime end they're
synthesizing they're adding dntps like
this right
5 4 3 prime and then they add 1 and it's
wrong right what if DNA put much makes
that mistake so it should be able to go
back and erase that right and then go
back and continue on further
polymerizing ok so 3 prime to 5 prime
exonuclease activity is the idea that
they can go backwards right they can go
from the three prime three prime end to
the fire towards the five prime end and
then you know and then get rid of their
incorrect dntp that they attached and
then add the correct one so this 3 prime
to 5 prime exonuclease activity why is
it important that they all have this
ability
well this ability is the proofreading
ability basically if if the DNA excuse
me this should say polymerase here if
the DNA polymerase makes a mistake and
adds an incorrect base for instance if
there was supposed to add a TA and it
added a G that the problem has to go
back and fix that so in order to go back
and fix that it needs to take off the T
and then add a G so we can go back take
it off and add the correct base that in
order to take it off and needs to add
the exonuclease activity and it's it's
going from the it's going backwards it's
going 3 prime to 5 prime so the 3 prime
to 5 prime activity exonuclease activity
is a proofreading ability now they all
have these traits in common now what
makes some of these special DNA
polymerase one is special because it has
it has 5 prime to 3 prime exonuclease
activity
that's a little bit interesting what's
the purpose of that so why would that be
useful or necessary at all well if you
think about this this is going to
actually be involved in removal of the
RNA primer so recall from the last video
that we mentioned that aren't RNA
polymerase or primary specifically adds
an RNA primer right at the five prime
end and then DNA polymerase can begin to
go so DNA polymerase what it does is it
goes over and it sees this primer and
what it does is it goes through five
from the three prime Kutz it away and
replaces it with DNA okay so it cuts it
away and then replaces it with DNA okay
so it's involved in removing the RNA
primer it wouldn't be able to do that
without this five prime to three prime
exonuclease activity and it's the only
one of these three that has that keep in
mind these three DNA polymerases are
only in prokaryotes now there's nothing
really special about DNA polymerase two
that I want to mention but DNA
polymerase 3 it is it also has a fun
fact associated with it hence these pink
stars here so DNA polymerase 3 has the
highest what we call processivity
processivity what does that mean what
that means is that it can incorporate
the highest number of dntps before
falling off so now all these DNA
polymerases can add dntps and make DNA
but how many can they each add before
they fall off the the complex so
polymerase one can add approximately 200
before it falls off DNA polymerase 2
could add about 1,500 DNA polymerase 3
can about half a million that's insane
okay so clearly this one is really
really good at going through and just
adding dntps
before it falls off so
it's actually the primary DNA polymerase
involved in actually extending a DNA
chain okay
so I hope that little overview of the
DNA polymerase is was helpful this is
important as we talk about the actual
replication fork
I hope that was helpful one last thing
I'm a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email look for University at gmail.com
and into the description below for more
details
thank you for watching